le quartier de la Défense n'est qu'à une
dizaine de kilomètres et pourtant ici on
cultive de la salade en grande quantité
23 millions de plans sur cette plaine de
montée sont considérés comme la capitale
francilienne de la plante potagère 250
hectares d'exploitation maraîchères à
monter son Sartrouville et
Carrières-sur-Seine sur lesquelles les
Yvelines comptent s'appuyer pour aller
vers plus d'indépendance en matière
d'alimentation trouver des solutions et
des solutions durables et là parce que
les Yvelines se lancent dans un vaste
programme
d'autosuffisance alimentaire alors le
mot est un peu grand parce que on est
bien conscient que on y arrivera pas
mais on voudrait consommer de plus en
plus de produits Vinois et faire que les
produits Vinois deviennent majoritaires
dans l'assiette des Yvelines c'est
pourquoi une rencontre avec les
exploitants de la plaine étaient au menu
de la visite du canton de Houilles ces
maraîchers ont pu faire remonter au
président du Département quelques-unes
de leurs attentes pour améliorer leur
quotidien parmi eux Robert agriculteur à
Montesson depuis 1981 il y a certains
points d'amélioration qui à apporter sur
cette plaine notamment l'amélioration de
la structure foncière de la plaine on a
également un problème sur l'accès à
l'eau qui soit compatible en qualité en
quantité et surtout en prix avec notre
activité de production de légumes et
puis ensuite des accès à des marchés
publics divers pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues de la pleine de Montesson il
faut réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
les aider je pense que ça doit pouvoir
se faire après sur les questions de
foncier donc d'acquisition foncière
c'est plus compliqué parce que les
sommes sont substantielles le
département a lancé des assises de
l'alimentation des buffets des groupes
de travail vont se réunir pendant 4 mois
avant l'annonce de mesure concrètes sur
le sujet